When Steve and I wrote,
the lobby was pretty much in charge
of the discourse
and pretty much in charge of policy.
But that has changed.
The West is leading
Ukraine down the primrose
path, and the Israelis
are executing a genocide in Gaza.
It's not China's fault
that it wants to be powerful.
So if you get into trouble
and you dial 911,
there's nobody at the other end.
Hello this is John Mearsheimer, and in today's
episode, I would like to talk about
the new book on the Israel lobby
by Eli Clifton and Ian Lustick.
It's called Israel's Lobby.
America in the grip of a Foreign Power.
I think this is a truly important book,
and I hope that all of the viewers
go out and buy a copy
and read it very carefully.
Of course,
this is a subject that's dear to my heart
because along with Steve Walt,
I wrote an article and a book
on the subject of the Israel
lobby back in 2006 2007.
Steve and I wrote the article,
which appeared in the London
Review of Books in 2006.
And then, of course,
our book came out, The Israel Lobby
and US Foreign Policy in 2007.
And what I'd like to do is tell you why
I think that the new book by Eli
Clifton and Ian Lustick, is so important.
And in the process,
I want to do that by comparing it to the
book that Steve and I wrote.
This book is not
just an updated version
of what Steve and I wrote.
This book has all sorts
of new insights in it
that people should consider
very seriously.
And the way I'd like to proceed is,
first of all, I just like to talk
about what
the basic arguments are in the two books.
Then I'd like to talk about
the underlying conceptual framework
that has to underpin
any discussion of the Israel lobby
and of course, underpins both
the book Steve and I wrote in the book
that Eli and Ian wrote.
And then I want to talk about the nitty
gritty changes that have taken place since
2006, 2007
that, of course, heavily inform
this new book called
Israel's Lobby.
Let me just start off
with the core arguments.
Both of us or both books argue
that there is an Israel lobby
that is very powerful.
Now, it's very important to emphasize that
in both books, the authors
go to great lengths to make it clear that
this is not a Jewish lobby by any means.
It's an Israel lobby.
Not all Jews by any means
belong to the Israel lobby.
And the Israel and the Israel lobby,
of course, includes
many non-Jews,
Christian Zionists, for example.
So this is not the Jewish lobby,
it's the Israel lobby.
Now, the argument that Steve
and I made the principal argument
was that the lobby is bad
for American foreign policy.
It's bad for a strategic point of view.
And from a moral point of view.
And in the absence of the lobby,
the United States, we argued, would have
a very different foreign policy,
especially in the Middle East.
We did not say
much in our written work
about the importance
of the lobby for Israel.
Nor did we say much about the importance
of the lobby
for the American Jewish community.
Nor did we say much,
if anything, about the impact
that the lobby has
on American liberal democracy
or on American political institutions.
But it's important to understand
that the book by Eli Clifton
and Ian Lustig
not only argues that
the lobby is bad
for American foreign policy.
It is that it's bad for Israel.
It argues that it's bad for American Jews,
and very importantly,
it argues that it now is in a position
where it's
undermining,
undermining liberal democracy.
So the charge in the new book
is much broader
than the charge in the book
that Steve and I wrote.
Now, what about the underlying
conceptual framework?
Anytime you think about the lobby,
you have to think about its influence
on the discourse.
This is the discourse about Israel,
the discourse
about the US-Israeli relationship
and the discourse about the lobby itself.
So the question
is, how does the lobby influence
that discourse?
Then there's the issue of actual policy.
And the question is
how does the lobby influence policy,
which is different from the question of
how does the lobby influence discourse?
Now, our argument
back in 2006, 2007 was that the lobby
did a very effective job at, in effect,
controlling the discourse.
Or if you want to put it in slightly
different words,
policing the discourse on Israel.
And we described in
great detail how The Lobby did that.
We tried to account for the success
that the lobby
had had up to that point
in managing the discourse
in ways that were favorable
from the lobby's perspective.
And with regard to policy,
there was just no question
that the lobby had a
hammerlock on US Middle East policy.
This is not to say
it got its way every time, but
it got its way almost every time.
And oftentimes when it didn't get its way,
it ended up
forcing the administration
to change its policy
to accommodate Israel and the lobby.
So the basic argument
that Steve and I made
was that the lobby was very successful
in terms of controlling the discourse,
policing the discourse,
and certainly in terms of influencing
policy in ways that the lobby wanted
that policy to go.
Now, the argument
in the Clifton
Lustig book is very different.
There is that the lobby has lost
its ability to control the discourse,
but it has not lost
its ability to control policy.
So you see the fundamental change
between our book
and their book,
and it has to do with the discourse.
Let me give you a sense of how I see
the discourse having changed
since we wrote the book back in 2007.
And the article, of course, before
that, in 2006, when we wrote the book,
it was almost impossible
to talk about dual loyalty.
And if you did talk about dual loyalty,
you had to deal with it very carefully,
very gingerly.
It was a remarkably hot topic.
If you look at
the discourse today, people
not only talk about individuals
having dual loyalty,
they talk about Israel Firsters
the term Israel Firster, in other words,
someone who privileges Israel's interests
over America's interest is a term
that's used all the time.
In fact, many prominent American Jews
who are
pro-Israel
are referred to as Israel firsters.
This was not an argument anyone,
including Steven and I would want to make.
In 2006 or 2007.
But the discourse has changed to the point
where you can make
that argument to take
what's going on in Gaza.
The lobby and Israel have gone
to enormous lengths to say that
this is not a genocide.
What the Israelis are doing
in Gaza against the Palestinians,
a center for Jewish Studies
at Brandeis,
just recently released a report that shows
that 74% of college
students, 74% of college students,
think that
what Israel is doing in Gaza
against the Palestinians is a genocide.
This is remarkable.
And this is evidence
that the lobby has lost
its ability to control the discourse.
And of course, you see this
with people like
Tucker Carlson
and Candace Owens and so forth and so on.
There's just no question
that the discourse today
is fundamentally different than it was in
2006, 2007.
Now, with regard to policy,
there's no question, as Ian or
Ian and Eli make clear, that that the lobby
still has a stranglehold on U.S.
Middle East policy.
And the issue that they raise,
of course,
which is a fascinating issue, is
whether or not
and I'll talk more about this at the end.
You can sustain a situation
where Israel loses
control the discourse
and people in the public domain
talk about Israel in ways that are at odds
with policy toward Israel.
In other words, it's very hard
to have a special relationship with Israel
where you give Israel
unconditional support when so many people
in the body populace have a negative view,
a hostile view, in many cases of Israel.
So the story that Ian and Eli are telling
is that the discourse has changed
fundamentally
since when Steve and I wrote a book,
but the policy has not.
Now let's talk about the specifics.
Let's talk about
what has actually happened
to change the discourse.
And then let's then switch gears
and talk about how the lobby has reacted
to this deteriorating situation
from their point of view,
in terms of the discourse,
how the lobby is reacting to that,
and how the lobby is working
overtime today
to make sure that it maintains
its profound influence on U.S.
Middle East policy.
In other words,
that the United States remains firmly
committed
to giving Israel unconditional support.
What is what is
what is the lobby, Israel's
lobby, doing today to ensure that happens?
So let's just start by talking
about what has changed.
And here we're focusing on the discourse.
At the risk of sounding
like engaged in self-promotion,
I do think Steve and I, with our article
and with our book,
played a key role
in opening up the discourse on Israel.
Of course,
there were all sorts of other people
who wrote before us
and after us who helped in that endeavor.
But I think there's no question that
the discourse
was helped by our article
and then by our book.
And I would marry this
to the coming of the internet.
The internet has been a huge problem
for Israel.
And what's going on here
is that in the past,
before the coming of the internet,
almost everybody relied
on the mainstream media for their news
about the Middle East, for their news
about Israel, for their news
about the US Israeli relationship.
And there's no question
the lobby had a profound influence
on what was said in the mainstream media.
But with the coming of the internet,
you have the growth
of all sorts of platforms,
the growth of an alternative media
and alternative to the mainstream media,
where it's possible to say things
that are critical of Israel,
to post videos
of what Israel is doing in Gaza,
which is guaranteed
to make Israel look bad and
guaranteed to
change the discourse on Israel.
The US Israel relationship
and on the lobby itself.
So one cannot underestimate
the importance of the internet,
the importance of platforms
like TikTok, of YouTube, of Substack
for allowing criticism of Israel
and the US Israeli relationship
and the lobby itself
to percolate out into the discourse,
the mainstream discourse.
So the internet has really mattered.
What's also really mattered,
obviously, is Israeli behavior.
And Clifton and Lustig
are really good on this whole issue.
And in fact, they have a chapter
on Israel as a crazy state
that everybody should read very carefully.
But what's going on here?
First of all, as a result of October
7th, 2023,
Israel set out
to expel the Palestinians from Gaza,
and in the process,
it ended up executing a genocide.
And this was a genocide
that virtually everybody on the planet
watched on the internet.
It was perfectly obvious
what the Israelis were doing.
And furthermore, a discourse began
to open up about Israeli policy
towards the Palestinians over time.
This is a discourse that hardly
anybody in the public knew about.
But it became clear to all sorts of people
that if you looked at his
looked at Israeli behavior
towards the Palestinians over time,
at least going back to 1948,
when the state of Israel was created,
that the Israelis often treated
the Palestinians
in absolutely horrible ways.
And then, of course,
you've got a genocide on top of that.
So I think if you look at
what the Israelis were doing.
Not just in Gaza, but beyond Gaza.
If you look at what they're doing
in the West Bank today,
it's hard
not to be super critical of Israel.
And this,
of course, is exactly what happened.
You want to remember,
I said that this Brandeis Center
did a survey
that showed that 74% of college students
think that Israel
is committing a genocide in Gaza.
There's a reason for this,
and that is that I am sure
most of those students have watched
what's happening in Gaza
and read about what's happening in Gaza
on TikTok
or YouTube or Substack,
and this is a huge problem for Israel.
So what I'm saying here is that it's
really behavior coupled with the internet,
that has really changed
how people think and talk about Israel.
Now, to take this a step further
in this chapter on Israel
as a crazy state,
Ian and Eli
tell a very interesting story about this
whole concept of a crazy state,
and they link it very carefully to Israel.
When I was young,
when I was a graduate student,
there was a book that most of my fellow
IR students read by an Israeli
called Yehezkel Dror,
and it dealt
with the subject of crazy states.
I believe that was the title of the book.
Crazy States, if my memory is correct,
and Dror who was an Israeli.
Of course, his basic argument was that
there are some states in the system
that have almost unlimited goals,
unlimited aggressive goals,
and they're willing to employ
almost any means, no matter how barbaric,
to achieve those unlimited goals.
And of course, the canonical case here
was Nazi Germany.
And the argument was,
and it was not a difficult argument
to make, was that Nazi Germany
had extremely ambitious goals.
They were horrible goals,
they were aggressive goals,
and they were willing to employ
the most horrendous
or barbaric means to achieve those goals.
And as Lustig and Clifton pointed out,
the purpose of Dror's book was
to make the argument that the Arab states
surrounding Israel were crazy states,
and therefore Israel was justified
to do almost anything it had to do to deal
with these crazy states.
I mean, what else could Israel do
if it was surrounded by crazy states,
but behave in the most hard
headed and toughest possible way
with these crazy states?
And the point that Dror
oh, excuse me,
the point that Lustick and Clifton
are making
is that what's happened over time is it's
not the Arab states that surround Israel
that have turned out to be crazy states.
It's Israel itself
that's turned out to be a crazy state.
And the argument they make
is that if you look at Israeli
goals in the Middle East, the emphasis on
creating a greater Israel, the emphasis
on wrecking all of Israel's
powerful neighbors
and so forth and so on.
And then if you look at the means
that Israel applies
to achieve these goals, starting
wars, assassinating leaders and so forth
and so on.
You see very clearly in their story
that Israel
has become a crazy state.
And this argument is laid out
in considerable detail,
and it is a very powerful argument.
And if you think about it, this behavior
reflects how Israel acts these days.
And of course, getting back
to what I was saying a minute ago,
it's very clear to people who watch,
you know, TikTok, YouTube,
who reads Substack posts and so forth
and so on, that Israel is behaving
like a crazy state.
And of course, once
people become aware of this,
the discourse is going to change.
And that's really what's happening here.
If you look at Israeli behavior
and you marry that to the fact
that this behavior is apparent
to so many people in the West,
in the United States in particular, it's
hardly surprising what's going on here.
It's hardly surprising
why Israel is losing the American public.
They also make another
very important argument, which you hardly
see talked about in the American media,
which is worth saying a few words about.
And this has to do with Israel's
sense of itself.
It has to do with Israeli identity.
And they point out that this is not only
about Israeli identity, it's
also about the identity that a number of
American Jews have as well.
And when I was younger and
the first time I went to Israel,
which I believe was in 1978,
I was of the belief
that Israel was striving
to become what was referred to
at the time as a normal country.
Israel was going to become
just another nation state.
It's going to be closely
affiliated with the West.
But it was a normal state.
I remember when I went to Israel in 1978,
and somebody told me that
when it became clear that there were
a significant number of Israeli
prostitutes, that many Israelis thought
that was a good thing, because it showed
that Israel was a normal country
and it was just another nation state.
The Jews were finally getting
their own state, much
the way the French had their own state,
or the Japanese had their own state.
The Jews now had their own state.
It was just another nation
state on the planet.
And Ian and Eli point out
that this is only one
strand in Jewish thinking or Israeli
thinking.
Let's talk about it in those terms.
There's only one strand in Israeli
thinking these days.
There's another strand and that strand,
which has a rich history,
basically argues that Jews as a nation
will dwell alone and will be not,
will not be reckoned among nations.
Just think about that rhetoric
that Jews are not a normal nation,
and they will not.
They will dwell alone there alone,
and they will not be reckoned
among nations.
This is not just the normal nation state.
And furthermore, they point out
that part of this worldview.
This is the opposite worldview from
the one that Israel is a normal state.
This is saying Israel is very special.
It will dwell alone is the whole notion
that the world is against us.
They're out to get the Jews
and they're out to get Israel.
And furthermore,
and this is rhetoric that they use
in the book, the belief is,
according to this second worldview,
that Gentiles,
all Gentiles, are potential Nazis.
And the point that I and Eli make
is that if you look at survey data
regarding what is happening
inside of Israel, it's very clear
that this second view
that Israel will dwell alone
and that the world is against
Israel, has taken hold in a serious way.
And if anything, is likely to become
a more potent worldview in the years
ahead.
This reminds me that I often wonder
why the Israelis are not more concerned
about the fact that they have alienated
so many people around the world,
that they have done
so much damage to Israel's reputation.
If you think about the argument
that Ian and Eli are making,
it's perfectly understandable
in terms of the growing strength
of this second sense of Israeli identity,
why Israelis don't care
very much about what others think
about their behavior because they expect
other countries, other nation states,
other peoples to be against them.
That's just the way the world operates.
So the argument here is that
what's going on is not only that
there has been a fundamental change
in Israel's sense of its own identity.
And again, this bleeds over into
how many American Jews
think about themselves
and think about Jews in the world,
because, again, they are making
the argument that this line of argument
has affected
some American Jews as well as Israelis.
So you have this phenomenon
taking place at the same time.
Israel is behaving in barbaric ways
in places like Gaza and the West Bank.
And this is all taking place
in the age of the internet.
And as a result of all these factors.
What has happened here is that Israel's
situation, in terms of
the discourse has badly deteriorated.
The idea that most Americans
have a favorable view of Israel
and a favorable view of the U.S.
Israeli relationship,
which is what existed when Steve
and I wrote our article
and then our book has drastically changed,
and most Americans now
have a negative view of Israel.
And if anything, this is likely to change,
certainly,
given that Israel, according to Lustick
and Clifton, do not care
very much about what the rest of the world
thinks.
Number one and number two,
they feel they're basically free
to do as they want in places like Gaza.
Places like Syria, places like Lebanon,
and of course, the West Bank as well.
So Israel has lost control
and the lobby has lost
control of the discourse
for all these reasons.
And that situation
is not likely to change.
Now, as I said to you before
with regard to policy.
The policy has not changed.
The United States remains firmly committed
to supporting Israel unconditionally.
This is no question on that front.
So we have the situation today,
which Eli and Ian
and do a brilliant job of describing,
where the policy
and the discourse are out of sync.
So the question then is
what is the lobby doing
to number one,
try and rectify the discourse
or rectify the problem that it faces
in terms of the discourse.
And then number two.
What is it trying to do to make sure
that moving forward,
there's no change in American policy
toward Israel, that the lobby and Israel
working together,
continue to maintain a hammerlock on US
policy.
Let's start
by talking about the discourse.
And with regard to the discourse,
really two things are happening here
that they describe in considerable detail.
One has to do
with the definition of anti-Semitism.
When Steve
and I wrote the book back in 2007,
it was a pretty widespread understanding
of what anti-Semitism was.
And
what's happened over time
is the definition of anti-Semitism
has been broadened greatly.
And today, the lobby
and many others,
because of the power of the lobby
to spread this idea, have this very loose
definition of what anti-Semitism is.
It's the IHRA definition you're
saying to you.
So what does IHRA mean?
It's the International
Historical Remembrance Alliance,
excuse me, the International Holocaust
Remembrance Alliance,
International Holocaust Remembrance
Alliance, IHRA definition of anti-Semitism,
and that IHRA definition of anti-Semitism
is very broad.
And what it effectively means
is that criticism of Israel
is seen as anti-Semitism.
So anybody who is criticizing Israel
for its genocide in Gaza
or its barbaric behavior in places
like the West Bank is
said to be an anti-Semite,
according to this definition.
So what the lobby has tried to do
by deploying this IHRA
definition of anti-Semitism is make it
virtually impossible to criticize Israel
without putting yourself in a position
where you're labeled an anti-Semite.
When Steve Walt and I wrote our book,
we had a chapter
called The Great Silencer,
and we talked in that chapter
about how the charge of anti-Semitism is
used as the great silencer.
And of course, Eli and Ian
are talking about exactly that.
And they are dealing with this
IHRA definition, which is a very important
part of the story,
which was not part of the story
when we wrote our book.
So that's the first tool
that the lobby uses to combat
criticism of Israel.
In effect,
the aim here is to make criticism
of Israel anti-Semitic
and therefore silence critics.
The second thing that's happened
is that the lobby has used the government
to crack down on
anyone who criticizes Israel,
and the best example of that
were the protests that took place
all across college and university
campuses in the United States
in the spring of 2024.
Remember, after October 7th, 2023,
after the Hamas attack into Israel.
Israel went on the offensive and
eventually ended up executing a genocide.
And unsurprisingly, by the spring of 2024,
there were large scale,
if not massive, protests on campuses
all across the United States.
The lobby went to work
and put enormous pressure
on the US government
to shut down those protests.
And by the way,
this was not the Trump administration.
It was the Biden administration.
And the Biden administration
played ball with the lobby,
and those protests were shut down.
And if you go to university
or college campuses today,
you'll see remarkably little evidence
of any criticism of Israel.
It's really quite amazing
how good the lobby and the government
working together as a tag team,
have been at shutting down
criticism of Israel
on college and university campuses.
And of course, this is linked in part
to using that broad definition
of anti-Semitism purveyed by the lobby,
because if people on college campuses
set out to protest
Israeli behavior and criticizes
Israel or criticize the lobby
or criticize the US-Israel relationship,
what happens very quickly
is that the government defines that
as anti-Semitism and goes to work.
So this is how the lobby has been
trying to police the discourse.
Or, to put it slightly differently,
to sort of recapture
control of the discourse.
The fact is, it's failed.
There's just no question about that.
The lobby has been unable to recapture
control of the discourse.
And the main reason is the internet.
It's just almost impossible in the age
of the internet to control the discourse
the way the lobby once did
before the coming of the internet.
Then there's the question
of policy
what's going on at the policy level.
And there Clifton and
Lustic have a
Very interesting story to tell.
First of all, they talk about
the growth of plutocracy
in the United States,
the fact
that we have a large number of plutocrats,
some of whom are Jewish,
and those Jewish plutocrats are willing
to expand huge amounts of money
to influence elections,
both at the congressional level
and at the presidential level.
And not only that, not only do
we have this plutocrat class
that includes wealthy Jews
who are deeply committed to Israel,
but we also had a decision.
A Supreme Court decision was made in 2010.
This is the Citizens United decision
that basically allowed individuals.
In other words, these wealthy plutocrats
to spend almost as much money
as they want on congressional
and on presidential elections.
So you have this situation
where someone like Miriam Adelson,
who is both an Israeli citizen
and an American citizen
and who clearly identifies
more with Israel than the United States,
according to Donald Trump,
gave him an enormous
sum of money
which helped him to get reelected in 2024.
And of course, Miriam Adelson
was not the only Jewish plutocrat
who was supporting Donald Trump.
But the more general point here
is that in the United States of America,
we have a political system
where to get elected.
You need a lot of money, and
to get reelected, you need a lot of money.
And if you have plutocrats
who can spend unlimited sums of money
helping people get elected,
who are pro-Israel in their view,
and can help defeat candidates
or incumbents
who are viewed as anti-Israel,
in their view,
you're going to quickly reach a situation
where
most people on Capitol Hill
and almost all presidents
are going to be afraid to cross the lobby
and will do pretty much
what the lobby wants.
And of course, you saw this with Joe
Biden, and you see this with Donald Trump.
Neither Biden
nor Trump dare to cross the lobby.
And this has been true, of course,
for a long time in American politics.
And the reason is today
that you have all these plutocrats
who are deeply committed to Israel
and can spend endless amounts of money
because of the 2010 Citizens
United decision by the Supreme Court.
So what's the bottom line here?
The bottom line here
is that since Steve and I wrote our book,
the discourse about Israel has changed
drastically.
The public discourse about Israel
has changed drastically.
And as I said before,
that's due in large part to the internet,
coupled with Israeli behavior
and how Israel thinks about itself.
Those various factors have led
to this fundamental change
in the discourse,
but the policy has not changed.
The lobby is still able
to influence policy
in ways that the United States
maintains
unconditional support for Israel.
So the big question moving forward,
and this will be a question that 20 years
from now, the successors to Clifton
and Lustick will write write about.
The question is how successful
will the lobby be in the years
or in the years ahead
at maintaining support for Israel?
Unequivocal support
for Israel at the policy level,
when in fact support for Israel
has significantly deteriorated
at the popular level.
This is really the big question
moving forward.
This was not a question
that Steve and I faced when we wrote.
I want to emphasize that again.
When Steve and I wrote,
the lobby was pretty much in charge
of the discourse
and pretty much in charge of policy.
But that has changed.
Lobby has lost its ability
to control the discourse.
And again,
what you want to think about moving
forward is what effect
this will have on policy, on US policy
toward Israel in the years ahead.
So on that note, I will conclude,
and I just want to say again,
I think that people
who are interested in US
Middle East policy, who are interested in
how the lobby influences that policy,
you should definitely go out
and read this new
book by Ian Lustig and Eli Clifton,
because it's a superb book
and it says all sorts of interesting
and important things about the lobby
and about Israel,
and about the effect
the lobby is having on US democracy.
This is not a small issue,
and this is an issue
that I have not dwelled on today,
but which these authors
spend a lot of time
talking about in their new book.
On that note,
let me close and say thank you
for watching this episode
and I look forward to the next episode.